ضربه كبيره للحوثيين تشكل قلقا بالغا في
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه العقم يهدد الجنود
العبريين المشاركين في الحرب على القطاع
فما السبب موسكو تصرح واشنطن منخرط في
مشاريع سريه لمنع انشاء دوله فلسطينيه
تدخل روسي لاجل معارك الحدود اللبنانيه
ملثم القطاع يعود من جديد ليعلن الحصيله
ومجلس الامن الروسي شكرا للاتحاد الاوروبي
على النمو ما الذي يجري تشاؤم غربي غير
مسبوق من اي هجوم اوكراني وبوتين يوجه
تحذيرا خطيرا جديدا
للغرب من الذي يطلب الهدنه على وقع
التحركات الدوليه ومع ازدياد الضغط
الداخلي في تل ابيب ها هي الهدنه تقترب
كما يقول المراقبون ليؤكد المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي
وجود محادثات جاريه بشان هدنه جديده
محتمله بين تلبيب والفصائل واصفا اياها
بالج ده للغايه فيما نقلت صحيفه ديعت احر
نوت عن مصادر ان تلبيب اقترحت صفقه تبادل
على مرحلتين على ان تشمل المرحله الاولى
من الصفقه تبادلا للاسرى وتشمل المرحله
الثانيه صفقه شامله فيها كل الخيارات
واضافت الصحيفه ان الفصائل ترفض كافه
مقترحات التبادل التي لا تشمل وقف اطلاق
النار واليكم المصدر مشاهدينا فقط
استكمالا ل ما كنا اوردناه في عواجل عن
يدعو احرنوت التي تحدثت عن ان اسرائيل
تقدمت
بمقترح يحدد مرحلتين المرحله الاولى هي
لتبادل الاسرى دون وقف لاطلاق النار بحسب
مصادر اسرائيليه والمرحله الثانيه ستشمل
كل الخيارات
ليستبدل ابري بنيامين نتنياهو التواصل الى
وقف لاطلاق النار في القطاع قبل ان يتم
القضاء على الفصائل واضاف لن نتوقف عن
القتال حتى نحقق كل الاهداف التي وضعناها
لانفسنا من جهتها قالت مصادر مصريه مطلعه
ان وفدا من الفصائل يضم قيادات يزور مصر
لاجراء محادثه مع كبار المسؤولين المصريين
لبحث ملف التهدئه وصفقه تبادل الاسرى ياتي
هذا فيما كشف موقع ولا العبري عن اقتراح
عرضته حكومه النتنياهو على الفصائل بهدنيه
لمده اسبوع لقاء الافراج عن 40 محتجزا
عبريا وها هو المصدر يتحدث موقع ولا
الاسرائيلي هو الاخر ونقلا عن سياسيين
اسرائيليين ومصدر غربي مطلع كشف عن عرض
قدمته حكومه نتنياهو على حركه حماس عن
طريق قطر يقضي بهدنيه تمتد لمده اسبوع على
الاقل لقاء الافراج عن 40 محتجز اسرائيلي
بينما اشارت صحيفه الجارديان بريطانيه الى
غضب دولي متزايد بين اقرب حلفاء تلبيب على
خلفيه الارتفاع الكبير في عدد الوفايات في
القطاع والماساه التي يعيشها اكثر من
مليون نازح في ظل غياب قدر كاف من الغذاء
والماء وفي صحيفه الول ستريت جورنال وجد
تقرير ان تحليلات الخبراء تشكك في قدره
تلبيب على تحقيق نصر في حربها ضد الفصائل
ضمن الجدول الزمني الذي يسعى المسؤولون
الامريكيون لالزام به هناك اعتبرت رئيسه
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ان الحرب في
القطاع تجسد الفشل الاخلاقيه للمجتمع
الدولي بسبب عجزه عن اثبات قدرته على وضع
حد للكارثه الانسانيه ليخرج وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سيرغي لافروف ويصرح بان موسكو
تتلقى العديد من التقارير التي تفيد بان
الغرب بقياده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
منخرط مره اخرى في مشاريع سريه لمنع انشاء
دوله فلسطينيه ميدانيا عدم لثم الفصائل
ابو عبيده للظهور من جديد في بيان اعلن
فيه انه تم تفخيخ نفقين ومنزل وتفجيره ما
بجنود من العبريين اضافه لقنص احد الجنود
مضيفا ان قوات الفصائل دكت مقرات وغرف
القياده الميدانيه والتحشير بقذائف الهاون
والصواريخ قصيره المدى واردف ابو عبيده ان
مقاتليهم قد تمكنوا خلال 72 ساعه من تدمير
41 اليه عسكريه عبريه كليا او جزئيا وقتل
25 جنديا عبريا واصابه عشرات اخرين بجروح
متفاوته لتعود صحيفه يد عوت احر نوت وتؤكد
ان الحرب تسبب اصابات بوليه واحيانا شديده
لدى جنود تلبيب المشاركين في الحرب على
القطاع والذين اصيبوا في المعارك وهم
مهددون بمشاكل مستقبليه في الوظيفه
الجنسيه والحفاظ على الخصوبه حث يهدد
العقم مئات الجنود وناتي
[موسيقى]
بالمصدر 13 العبريه نشرت تفاصيله صحيفه
تايمز اوف اسرائيل فقد وصلت قوات الجيش
العبري خلال الايام الاخيره الى انفاق
يعتقد ان زعيم ال صائل يحيى السنوار كان
مختبئا بها قبيل اكتشافه ولكنه افلت ونجا
من الاعتقال مرتين في اللحظات الاخيره
عادت القناه 13 العبريه لتعلن ان رئيس
الوزراء العبري النتنياهو طلب تاجيل جلسات
محاكمته متذرعا بانشغاله بالحرب على
القطاع في البحر الاحمر افاد موقع
بوليتيكو نقلا عن مسؤولين في البنتاغون
بان تكلفه اسقاط مسيرات وصواريخ الحوثيين
تشكل مصدر قلق متزايد لواشنطن واشار
الموقع ان صاروخا بقيمه مليوني دولار
استخدم لاعتراض مسيره للحوثيين بقيمه 1000
دولار وعلى الحدود اللبنانيه التقطت عدسات
صحفيين صور قصف عبري على اطراف بلدتين
حدوديت جنوبي لبنان وافادت وكاله الاناضول
بان المقاتلات الحربيه العبريه شنت عده
غارات على اطراف بلدتي حلتا وكفر شوب
الحدوديتين مشيرا الى انها استخدمت قنابل
الفسفور الابيض الحارق في قصفها على عده
اطراف لبلده حلتا فيما قالت المتحدثه باسم
وزاره الخارج جيه الروسيه ماريا زاخاروفا
ان موسكو تبذل كل ما في وسعها لمنع المزيد
من تصعيد التوتر على الحدود بين تلبيب
ولبنان واشارت الى ان الوضع على خط التماس
هناك له صله مباشره بما يحدث في القطاع
والمناطق
الاخرى خذلان
الحلفاء يقولها الغربيون بملء افواههم
حربنا قاب قوسين او ادنى من الخساره امام
بوتين هنا كشفت صحيفه نيويورك بوست
الامريكيه ان اي هجوم يشنه الجيش الروسي
على الجبهه في اوكرانيا سيكون بمثابه
كارثه بالنسبه للغرب مضيفه ان الغرب خذل
اوكرانيا لان حلفاء كياف لم يتمكنوا من
توفير الاسلحه اللازمه وفي الوقت نفسه قد
يتفاقم الوضع في البلاد في العام المقبل
بسبب نجاحات روسيا على خط الجابها فيما
اشارت صحيفه ديلي اكسبريس الى ان كلمات
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حول تحديث
القوات النوويه الاستراتيجيه للبلاد كانت
بمثابه رساله الى الغرب وقالت الصحيفه ان
بوتين اصدر تحذيرا خطرا جديدا للغرب قائلا
ان الاسلحه الموجوده تحت تصرف القوات
النوويه الروسيه تم تحديثها بنسبه
95% من جهته صرح نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي ديمتري ميدفيدف ان نمو الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي لروسيا يتناسب طردا مع
هبوط الاقتصاد الاوروبي وكتب ميدفيد
بالانجليزيه على صفحته في موقع اكس
الاتحاد الاوروبي شكرا لك على النمو بينما
اكد زعم مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي اقرار حزمه
المساعدات لاوكرانيا البالغه قيمتها 61
مليار دولار لن يحصل هذا العام على الرغم
من الحاح البيت الابيض على المشرعين بسرعه
اقرارها وبحسب وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه فان
ذلك يشكل خيبه لزل نسكي وانتكاسه لبايدن
ووفقا لشبكه ان بي سي يناقش المسؤولون
الامريكيون والاوروبيين بالفعل مع كياف
العواقب المحتمله لمحادثات السلام مع
روسيا بما في ذلك الخطوط العارضه لما قد
يتعين على اوكرانيا التخلي عنه من اجل
التوصل الى اتفاق فيما افاد مساعد نائب
وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق ستيفن بريان
لصحيفه ونز اند ستراتيجي بان استسلام
اوكرانيا سيكون اول هزيمه كبرى لحلفاء
النتو منذ انشاء الحلف من جانب اخر اعلنت
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ان الولايات
المتحده فرضت عقوبات جديده استهدفت فيها
اربعه شركات ناقله نفط مرتبطه بروسيا
واوضحت الوزاره ان العقوبات استهدفت كذلك
ناقله المنتجات النفطيه سنار 15 التي تبحر
رافعه العلم الروسي وفي الميدان الاوكراني
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط مروحيه
اوكرانيه من طراز م 24 و32 طائره مسيره
اوكرانيه خلال 24 ساعه واضافت الوزاره
الروسيه ان الجيش الروسي كبد القوات
الاوكرانيه خسائر فادحه بينها معدات غربيه
في
127 منطقه هنا افاد الجنرال المتقاعد من
القوات الاوكرانيه سيرجي كريفون وس بان
الطائرات الروسيه المسيره تدمر على الفور
كل المعدات الاوكرانيه التي تقترب من خط
المواجهه لانها بمجرد ظهورها على مسافه من
ثلاثه الى عه كيلومترات من خط المواجهه
تتعرض على الفور لهجوم بطائرات دون اليار
الروسي اضاف في بعض المناطق يصل الى 8
كيلومترات هذه هي الحقائق وها نحن نتصفح
المصدر
امامكم